celebrities and business leaders are
among 50 people who face criminal
charges in a giant College Admission
scam more arrests could come in the
weeks and months ahead
actress Lori Lachlan and Felicity
Huffman are two of the dozens of wealthy
parents accused in the alleged scheme
that lasted nearly one decade
prosecutors say some of them paid
millions to get their children into
elite schools like Yale Stanford and the
University of Southern California the
universities say they are victims Carter
Evans is at USC with the story of what
prosecutors call the biggest fraud case
of its kind in the u.s. Carter good
morning good morning more than a dozen
of the defendants allegedly bought their
way here into USC all told the 33 people
named in the indictment paid and alleged
25 million dollars in bribes and it
wasn't just Hollywood elite the
operation dubbed varsity blues also led
to charges against wealthy lawyers and
CEOs William singer left a boston
federal court yesterday after pleading
guilty to running the biggest College
Admission scam federal prosecutors have
ever seen
they say he became a cooperating witness
turning in a list clients their actions
were without a doubt insidious selfish
and shameful according to court
documents singer was the CEO of a
college prep company in California
parents spent as much as six and a half
million dollars to guarantee their
children's college admission the company
would not only help doctor SAT and a CT
test it would also create the false
impression the students were elite
athletes bribing coaches and creating
fake athletic credentials complete with
altered photos for kids some of whom
didn't even play the sports for which
they were recruited for every student
admitted through fraud an honest
genuinely talented student was rejected
as a student who got in for marriage
hearing about that absolutely you are
not going to believe what has happened
Desperate Housewives star Felicity
Huffman allegedly paid fifteen thousand
dollars to boost her daughter's SAT
score
her husband actor William H Macy was in
court with her as she was charged with
conspiracy and posted a $250,000 bond
well that's all the time we have today
Lori Lachlan of full house Fame is also
facing conspiracy charges
and is expected to surrender to
authorities today she and her husband
designer
Massimo gia newly allegedly paid half a
million dollars to have their two
daughters labeled as recruits to the USC
crew team even though neither
participated in the sport I'm gonna do a
dorm room tour today their 19 year old
daughter Olivia Jade is a social-media
influencer we have a nice carpet from
Amazon who apparently capitalized on her
experience at USC with sponsored posts
she had to apologize last year after
saying this on her YouTube channel I do
want the experience of like gamedays
partying I don't really care about
school as you guys all know this is not
just to me is not just an admission
scandal it's it's more broadly an
indictment of our entire educational
system and many colleges are already
taking action to athletics officials
here at USC that were allegedly involved
were fired yesterday
prosecutors say many of the students had
no idea what their parents had allegedly
done in this case Nora Marie Carter
thank you